to politics another court loss for the  trump campaign  today a wisconsin judge ruled against  the president's team and its effort to  disqualify more than 221 thousand  ballots the judge there in wisconsin  ruled against  every argument made by trump campaign  attorneys that were trying to challenge  ballots in wisconsin's two largest  counties from the bench the judge said  wisconsin's election  was properly administered and there was  no wrongdoing  president trump's attorneys do plan to  appeal and  they filed a separate federal lawsuit in  wisconsin as well  the electoral college is scheduled to  meet on monday wisconsin has 10  electoral votes